Liliane n'a que 9 mois mais elle est
comme déjà des déboires du réseau de la
santé elle n'a pas de médecin qui puisse
faire son suivi de croissance
pour nous
le jeune couple consulte donc un
infirmier praticien spécialisé au privé
et PM 1500 dollars pour les 6
consultations de la première année
ici plusieurs autres sont prêts à payer
pour être traitées
en 2016 depuis praxis a ajouté 4 autres
cliniques privées tout en banlieue de
Montréal c'est sûr que les couronnes
nord et sud de Montréal l'accessibilité
aux soins est quand même assez compliqué
proxy s'occupe dans le 45 0 l'espace
laissé par un secteur public déficient
et embauche une centaine de personnes
dont 38 infirmières praticiennes
spécialisées nous avons fait dans la
dernière année 48 000 consultations sur
cinq cliniques
sur les 48 000 consultations 78% ont été
effectués par nos infirmières pratiques
spécialisées les
IPs peuvent diagnostiquer des maladies
prescrire des examens et référer à des
spécialistes largement suffisantes pour
bien dépasser il y a des infirmières qui
sont aussi compétentes des fois si non
plus qu'un médecin et certains préfèrent
payer pour voir une infirmière plutôt
que d'attendre un médecin il y a pas de
médecin pour me faire
des crédit à votre dossier malgré les
coûts la clientèle ne serait pas
constitué uniquement de gens aisés
sont prêtes à payer pour avoir un
service
peu importe peu importe Valérie a quitté
le public en 2020 et n'a aucune
intention d'y retourner avec le réseau
actuel on l'a essayé on le retourne
notre bar le reste
c'est quelqu'un qui me dit que ça marche
moi les preuves le matin c'est ça
le recrutement ensemble aisé les
infirmières praticiennes disent avoir
réussi plus d'autonomie malheureusement
j'avais l'impression au public des fois
d'être là pour
avantagé les médecins ici infirmière et
patient ensemble avoir quitté le secteur
public pour de bon ici David gentil les
réseaux Canada Montréal